zu bewundern sind sie allein gekommen
nein mit meinem lebensgefährten der
finden adam und evelyn von andreas
goldstein ist eine männer und frauen
geschichte wie es einmal heißt in den
hintergrund allerdings die
weltgeschichte rumort denn das worum es
tatsächlich geht ist die wände der
wunsch steht er zu verlassen besteht
[Musik]
ich wollte nicht in den höchsten tönen
würde ich fast sagen empfehlen möchte
das kinojahr beginnt in deutschland mit
einem höhepunkt
ich habe aber erkennen wieso
die unterwegs aufgegabelt und über
geschlecht und unsere spielweise von der
adam und evelyn erzählt verläuft
allerdings ganz langsam
das ist im grunde auch schon eine
wesentliche punkte des films der ein
ganz eigenes tempo anschlägt und der
sich die zeit nimmt thema zur
verhandlung die eigentlich noch im wald
zurück führen zu der frage was das denn
damals war dieses geteilte deutschland
welche ideen von staatlichkeit von
gesellschaftlich kite diese beiden
systeme hatten und vor allem vielleicht
etwas was war die ddr mit lebensrecht
allerdings nicht warum eine große
sanftheit durchzieht den film eine
verhaltene komik ist wahrzunehmen
die figuren sind zurückhaltend sind
nichts groß aufgespielt aber es geht
tatsächlich ums jahr entscheidende dinge
das ist reichen fest
sie stellt fragen sie fahre irgendwo hin
zum balaton oder und in dieser
eigenwilligen perspektive vom rahmen
daher von einem umweg her auf die
weltgeschichte des großen jahre liegt im
grunde dann schließen sich heute von
bassermann ebelings an geschichte sonst
nicht
[Musik]